With these two completely different beliefs--Aristotle who says that objects fall
at a constant speed, and Galileo saying that objects gain speed as they fall,
how do we reconcile these different opinions?
Well, we're scientists. We look at the evidence. Let's look at two pieces of evidence in particular.
First, we have this idea that a mass dropped from a greater height leaves a greater impact,
and you could try this yourself.
Go outside and drop a brick from just barely off the ground
and then drop it again from higher off the ground.
You'll see that it'll make a bigger dent if you drop it from higher.
Now, Professor Settle mentioned earlier how difficult it is to actually
see anything when you drop an object.
Well, that's true except for when you drop something like a feather, and when you do that,
you can see that it really does tend to just drift down at more or less a constant speed.
Now, for each of these points, I want you to select one of these buttons.
Do this piece of evidence work in favor of Aristotle's belief or Galileo's
and likewise for this one so you should check two of these buttons.